انتقادات مربوحه وبابا المجال اشاده
برساله الامام محاضره العمده ارتباك في
دراما السوريه واليسا تفوز بانا وبس اليكم
الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
اعلنت المغنيه اللبنانيه اليسا حسم النزاع
القانوني بينها وبين زياد برجي حول ملكيه
اغنيه انا وبس لصالحها وتوجهت بالشكر
للقضاء اللبناني ومحاميها مارك حبقه ونشر
المنتج جانا عبر حسابه الرسمي على
تويتر خلاصه الحكم الذي يلزم الشاعر احمد
ماضي وبورجي بوقف استغلال الاغنيه وكان
السجال قد تصدر منصات التواصل في شهر مايو
ايار الماضي بين اليسا وزياد برجي بسبب
اصدار الاخير اغنيته كتير من الحانه
وكلمات احمد ماضي وذلك بعد فتره وجيزه من
اصداره اليسا للاغنيه ذاتها تحت عنوان انا
وبس
[موسيقى]
الواحد بيقول الحمد لله على السلامه
وحققت الحلقات الاولى من مسلسل الزند من
بطوله النجم السوري تيم حسن تفاعلا كبيرا
على منصات التواصل
[موسيقى]
وكذلك احتفى معجبون النجمين الذين سي
بنجيم وقصي خولي بثنائيه خيال وياقوت في
مسلسل واخيرا
[موسيقى]
اما مسلسل ابتسم ايها الجنرال وهو من
المسلسلات السوريه الاكثر ترقبا في رمضان
فقبلت حلقاته الاولى بنوع من خيبه الامل
التي طالت مدخل القصه وكذلك اداء عدد من
الفنانين بادوار اساسيه في العمل ما اضر
بايقاع الحلقات الاولى الى حد كبير بحسب
متابعين على منصات التواصل
ظالم
واحتفى متابعوه دراما المصريه بعوده
المسلسلات التاريخيه هذا الموسم من خلال
مسلسل رساله الامام وبساطه حوارات المسلسل
ووضوحها والاداء المتقن للابطال والرؤيه
الاخراجيه للمخرج السوري الليث حجو
[موسيقى]
تاني
وباذن الله اللي جاي زي الفل وطالت
الانتقادات صناعه مسلسل بابا المجال
الانفراد الممثل مصطفى شعبان بتدري بدايه
العمل دون ايراد اسماء باقي الممثلين
ومنهم فنانون مصريون كبار كسوسن بدر ورياض
الخولي ووجهت الفنانه رحمه احمد انتقادات
كبيره على ادائها في الحلقات الاولى من
مسلسل الكبير اوي 7 وتركزت الانتقادات على
الصراخ ونبرد صوت مربوحه لكن هناك من دافع
عنها في المقابل
[موسيقى]
وحظيت الفنانه روبي باشاده مايا مرسي
رئيسه المجلس القومي للمراه في مصر عن
مشهد ادته في مسلسل حضره العمده تقف فيه
بوجه ختان الاناث ووجهت مرسي تحيه للكاتب
ابراهيم عيسى والمخرج عادل اديب
مش حياتك الخاصه مش كده يا حضره الظابط
واخيرا ومع بدء موسم العرض الرمضاني في
مصر اعلن عن الاعمال المقرره عرضها في
النصف الثاني من الشهر وهي تحت الوصايه
جات سليمه ثلث الثلاثه تغيير جو والصندوق